[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEREN GIANNINI: Hello.
Welcome.
Welcome to this early
morning session.
Today we are going to talk
about operating serverless apps
and function with
Google Stackdriver.
I am Steren.
I am a Product Manager on
Cloud currently working
on serverless products.
Actually, before that, I built
Stackdriver Error Reporting.
JAY JUDKOWITZ: Good morning.
Thanks, everybody, who
braved the Thursday morning
after the party and
made it to the session.
My name is Jay Judkowitz.
I'm in product management
for Stackdriver.
I have a long career,
starting with back
in IT in the late 90s.
And I've always been
very fascinated with how
we make things better
and more available.
And so we're very excited
to bring that knowledge
and awareness that
Google's built up
and bring it to serverless
apps through Stackdriver.
So quick agenda.
First Steren is going to give
a good overview of serverless,
why serverless matters, what our
runtime choices are at Google
and how to pick one, and then
why monitoring in serverless
can be hard at times.
Then we're going to
switch over to me,
and I'm going to talk a
little bit about what Google
has learned from its 20
years in the business,
and particularly the
SRE discipline, which
we're trying more and more
to bring into Stackdriver.
And then we'll bring
that all together.
We'll talk about how SRE
knowledge works in Stackdriver
for serverless, and
we'll intersperse demos
with the whole thing
and not just do slides.
STEREN GIANNINI: Thank you, Jay.
So what is serverless?
You might have attended some
other sessions about it.
Let me recap today the
few characteristics
that we use to define serverless
products on Google Cloud.
The first one is that
a serverless product
is for developers.
Users of A serverless
product focus
on delivering business
value, focus on code.
The provider takes
care of the rest.
This is a key characteristic.
The second one is
that it scales.
Its scales to zero, which
means if you don't use it,
it will slowly get down to zero.
But if you use it a lot,
potentially it scales with you.
So really, there
is no provisioning
to do in advance, no management
of number of instances.
This is done for
you automatically.
The third characteristic
is that it is managed.
So by managed, of course,
the Cloud provider
is taking care of the
infrastructure for you,
is taking care of the updates
of this infrastructure,
of the reliability of
this infrastructure,
but also of the security.
And we provide a lot of security
features for our serverless
products out of the box.
So managed security, too.
The last point is
a billing model.
You really pay for what you use.
So because we have
this operational model,
where it scales up
and down following
your traffic, your needs,
we are able to provide you
a billing modeled where you
only pay when you use it.
So as a consequence,
you don't need
to commit to a certain
usage in advance.
You do not need to provision
certain cluster size.
No, no, no.
It's all based on what you need
at a certain point in time,
and you will only pay for that.
If you take those
characteristics,
you can see how it applies to
more than just small snippets
of code in the Cloud,
more than just functions.
If you take those
definitions, you
can see that we can apply
these to many areas,
like database, like storage,
like AI, like data processing.
All of these, Google
Cloud has products
that we qualify to be
serverless because they
answer so those points.
So you can see on
the data storage
side, one product
I really recommend
that is a great
pair with serverless
compute is a Cloud Datastore.
On the file storage side we
have Cloud Storage, PubSub,
Cloud ML Engine, BigQuery.
All of these you do not have to
care about the infrastructure.
You really pay when you use it.
So all of these are what
we qualify serverless.
For this talk, we are going to
focus on serverless compute.
So today all 2G [INAUDIBLE]
available products
in Google Cloud that
are serverless compute
are Cloud functions
that we announced
to be generally
available yesterday,
and App Engine that has
been here for a while
and loved by many,
many customers.
So these are all serverless
compute products.
And recently we
introduced a newcomer
in this picture, which is
the GKE Serverless Add-On.
So to be clear, the
GKE Serverless Add-On
allows you to get a serverless
developer experience
within your own
Kubernetes cluster.
But it does not provide you
with the serverless economics.
However, all of the
other attributes
are available for this product.
So it has been announced today
and is currently in alpha.
So this is a serverless compute
picture of Google Cloud.
Now I'm going to help
you a little bit picking
between these because I can
acknowledge that this might not
be easy sometime.
And the first one, Cloud
Functions, as the name
says, the unit is the function.
So here you are
going to really think
about not something
that does many purposes,
but only one thing.
So it's really well tailored for
single purpose microservices.
And because you can trigger
a function not only via HTTP
but also via events,
it will be a good fit
when you want to do asynchronous
workloads or things that
react after all something
in your Cloud architecture
has triggered.
So everything that is
event-based and async
are a good use case
for Cloud Functions.
Regarding event triggers, we
keep adding more and more.
To mention a few, you
can trigger a function,
of course, when there is
an HTTP request coming
in, but also for certain
logs for PubSub events,
when there is a database change,
like recently we announced
the availability of
Cloud file store events
for Google Cloud Functions.
You can trigger a function when
there is a new file in Cloud
storage, so really
many, many events,
and we are going to keep
adding more all the time.
This is Cloud Functions.
The second product I
mentioned is App Engine.
So App Engine, the unit
here is an application.
So an application will be source
code that you deploy and deploy
to App Engine.
The workloads that you
deploy to App Engine
are triggered via HTTP.
So that means that HTTP
coming from the outside world,
so if, for example,
you are going
to create a mobile API or just
a website with a front end
and multipurpose websites, then
App Engine is a very good fit.
Also, those HTTP requests
coming from the inside.
So you might have an
architecture with many services
and services talking
to each other,
and they obviously can
use HTTP to do that.
So App Engine would be best used
when you migrate an existing
code base because, as
we've announced yesterday,
we now have what we call the
App Engine second generation run
times.
And those are what
we say idiomatic.
So what does that mean?
That you can take any module
in your favorite programming
language and bring
them on App Engine.
And it's all serverless.
If you are a Node.js
developer, you
can use any modules
from NPM, be it
a regular one or a native
one, like something
that uses binary code.
You can do it on App
Engine standard now.
We announced recently the
availability of Python 3
and PHP 7 on App
Engine standard.
So also something that really
scales down to zero and scales
with you to snapshot scale.
App Engine has been
here for a while.
But if you take
the characteristics
of what a serverless
service is, App Engine
is serverless, App
Engine standard.
And the last newcomer is
the GKE Serverless Add-On.
So here the unit is
the container image.
So of course the add-on allows
you to build from source
to image, but at the end
of the day, the things that
are running and scaled for
you are container images,
even if you built
them from source using
[INAUDIBLE] tooling.
So when would you pick that one?
You would pick it when you're
coming from a Kubernetes world
and you want to give
to your developers
in your organization a
serverless experience.
Developers should not have to
worry about pods and replica
sets and scaling those pods.
No.
They just want to deploy
code, and they want things
like the system to
handle the rest.
And this system is what the
serverless add-on gives you.
So you take it when you
already have a GKE cluster,
when you want to stay in it.
You would pick
that when you have
some special needs of resources
that App Engine or Cloud
Functions do not give
you, so for example,
custom VM sizes or you
want to access GPU.
Or you will pick
that, for example,
when you want to be close
to another workload that
is already in GKE.
So let's assume you have an
elasticsearch service running
on GKE.
Then if you want your serverless
workloads to be close to it,
then this will be a good fit.
So the GKE Serverless Add-On
is currently in alpha,
but all of what we are going to
talk about later apply to it,
too.
So this is a picture of the
serverless in Google Cloud.
However, there are
some challenges
monitoring serverless.
The first one will be that by
definition, the servers are not
accessible.
So that means a few things.
That means that for App
Engine and Cloud Functions,
you don't control the OS.
So if you, for example, have
to install a particular agent,
monitoring agent, you can't.
So that presents a challenge.
Also, in the past we just
SSH'd into an instance
to see what's wrong.
Well, you can't in Cloud
functions or App Engine.
This is not something
we give you.
You cannot just
SSH the usual way.
So we'll see how we provide
tools to address that.
Then, serverless encourages
to break the monolith
into independently
scalable pieces,
because obviously if those
pieces can scale up and down
to zero, then breaking
them into pieces
will be better
economics for you.
If each of them can scale to
zero when you don't need them,
that's what you
would be looking for.
So as a consequence, serverless
encourages microservices.
And microservices mean
that you have more pieces
to monitor and
operate and to look,
to trace between all of these.
So we'll see how we
can help with that.
Another point is auto scaling.
As I said, a serverless
product scales with you.
So when you don't have any
requests, there is no instance,
so there is nothing
to look, to monitor.
And when the traffic
comes in, then instances
are scheduled for you, and
then automatically they
are stopped when it's needed.
Also, you cannot rely on the
fact that an instance will be
here a long time.
No, instances are spin up
and stopped very frequently
in serverless.
So what does that mean?
That means that first,
you really cannot look
at the instance level.
You really should look
at the service level.
The second is that
cold starts matter.
As you know, if instances
are started and stopped very
frequently, then you cannot do
a lot of things at startup time.
So you cannot load many
modules, many monitoring agents,
when things start.
And for functions, it's
even going one step further,
which is that in
Cloud functions,
outside of the execution
of the request,
you cannot do anything.
So that means that you cannot
expect to have CPU outside
of the request
response time frame.
So that's our third challenge.
And lastly,
serverless, as I said,
allows you to build
asynchronous workloads.
Here, for example, you
can react to an event.
You can use a queue
to enqueue some tasks.
We have Cloud tasks that we
released to beta recently.
You can use PubSub
topics to send events
across your microservices.
So all of this makes it harder
to see what triggered what
in your microservices.
So we will see later
how Stackdriver can help
you address those challenges.
Jay?
JAY JUDKOWITZ: Thanks, Steren.
So like I said, Stack driver
is really, really fortunate
to be a part of Google,
where we have at our disposal
the whole SRE team to learn from
to see how they built Google
to where it is.
And did everybody see the
book that they released
and Revision 2
that just came out?
So I definitely encourage that.
It's really good reading.
So what did we learn from SRE?
And how are we taking
advantage of that?
So Google has eight services
with a billion or more users.
We have 2,500 SREs.
And the math doesn't
really work this way,
but that's over 400,000
users served per SRE, which
is incredible economy of scale.
And not only that, the
SREs have a great culture
and love their work.
And so this is a thing that
customers have come and said.
Hey, we'd like to be
able to have a great ops
culture that scales and really
takes care of our customers.
Now to do this, they've
had to solve really
one huge trade-off.
On the one hand, reliability.
Google.com is sort of
synonymous with my internet up.
It's pretty reliable.
But on the other
hand, they're trying
to figure out how to
keep Google engineers as
productive as possible.
How can we experiment?
How can we release?
How can put out
new functionality?
And as you know, change
is the biggest thing
that affects reliability.
So balancing between
those two things
is the main challenge of SRE
and why they've developed
the culture they have.
So I'm not going to
do a whole SRE talk.
That would be an
hour on its own.
But I'll say from
the Stackdriver side,
what have we observed about SRE
that's special and different?
And what are the
ingredients that
are needed to pull together?
So the first piece is culture.
SREs aren't running around with
a pager playing whack-a-mole
with problems all day.
That would just not scale, and
they wouldn't be happy, either.
In fact, most
on-call shifts only
result in a couple
of pages a week.
What are SREs doing,
then, before an incident?
They're working on automation,
automating all the monitoring,
automating all data collection,
automating all of the responses
to simple problems
that can be handled
without human intervention.
They're also helping the
application developers
engineer the reliability
into the product.
They do the production
readiness reviews.
They say whether something is
ready to go live at huge scale.
They say whether it's really
worthy of having the pager
taken by the SRE team.
They're also responsible for,
when there is an incident,
the incident response process.
We won't talk about that
here, but that's in the book.
It's a really interesting,
scalable, predictable system
in the face of what
could be chaotic events.
They're responsible for the
blameless postmortems, which
are really important
because you're never
going to keep improving
reliability and agility
if you're not able to
look back at problems
and see what caused them
without people being afraid
of some kind of repercussions.
Now the most important part
of what the SREs work on
is SLOs, the service
level objectives.
That drives everything
we do and drives
how we think about reliability.
I'm not going to
describe that here
because there's a slide
and a feature that
will go into that in
detail and apply that
to the serverless products.
Now if you're an
SRE team, and you're
outnumbered by over 10 to 1,
and everything you're doing
is data driven, particularly
SLO work, imagine
a conversation where you go to
all these engineers and say,
I want you to give me this
metric, this metric, this log,
this thing, that thing.
And I you to do it and keep
up with my thinking on how
monitoring should evolve.
It'd be a short
conversation, right?
It's pretty hard to get all
these people to give you
exactly what you want.
So at Google, what we
did is we baked this
into the infrastructure.
When a Google Developer
deploys a service,
that service is well-defined.
It's discoverable.
It has an identity.
Things like quota
and permissions
are config on that system.
And there's automatic telemetry.
There's a baseline of
telemetry that every service
has that comes from the
infrastructure the developer
doesn't have to worry about.
This keeps the developers
very productive.
And it keeps the
SREs full of the data
that they need and removes
the fundamental tension that
could be there if we
weren't careful about that.
Now you don't all work at
Google and don't develop
on Google infrastructure.
But we've baked these principles
into the serverless runtimes.
So functions and App Engine and
the Serverless Add-On, the GKE,
all return standardized
metrics that
can be used in a standardized
way in the Stackdriver
dashboards that
we'll be showing.
We've also open sourced other
nifty things inside Google
that are pretty helpful.
So Stubby is our
Secure RPC mechanism.
That's open sourced to GRPC.
And Census, our
open source library
for collecting metrics
and traces that's
been released as open census.
Now Google's a big place.
And so if every app
is automatically
getting all these signals sent,
that turns into a lot of stuff.
So we have petabytes
of logs every day,
billions of monitored
resources, hundreds of billions
of time series.
Where does that all go?
Well, you need a platform
that scales to handle that.
You need to be able to
store it, keep it safe,
query it, do analytics on it.
And we're not going
to talk about this.
It's not the topic
of the presentation.
But note that that is the
bottom half of Stackdriver.
When you use Stackdriver,
you're putting your metrics,
your logs, your traces in
the same robust and scalable
systems that Google
engineers are.
The last piece, and this
is where we're really
going to focus, is the tools.
It's kind of the
tip of the iceberg.
Everything that I
talked about before
is that giant iceberg
under the water.
What's above the
water is the tools.
How do I implement this
operational culture,
taking advantage of all this
data and doing useful things?
And that's what we're going
to go into detail about
and demonstrate for you
is Stackdriver front end.
So what tools are available for
serverless from Stackdriver?
So what are the columns?
First is monitoring.
This is basically your
metrics, whether it's
coming from the infrastructure
or custom metrics
coming from the app.
It can be uptime checks.
It can be log counts.
But all of these
metrics are stored.
They're queryable.
You can set alerts and
notifications on them,
create incidents when
they go out of whack.
And so that's the core
piece that you expect
from monitoring solution.
Then there's logging
and error reporting.
Logging is collection of logs,
error reports or special logs
that are tied to stack
traces and often times
you want to do
special analytics on.
Lastly is application
performance management.
That is our tracing
product, distributed trace,
we'll talk about.
Our continuous profiler,
which helps you manage costs.
And the live debugger,
which lets you
figure out the state of
your application down
to the variable level
without pausing, redeploying,
or crashing the app.
As you can see,
green check marks
all across the board
for App Engine.
We've supported that
for quite a long time.
In fact, a lot of these
products supported App Engine
before they supported
anything else.
Cloud Functions monitoring,
logging, error reporting work,
no question.
The APM tools also
work, but some
of the libraries
and instrumentation
need to be optimized
for the function world.
So definitely encourage
people to try it out.
And it may or may not
be ready for production
for your functions, depending.
Lastly, GKE
Serverless Add-On on.
The Stackdriver team
and the serverless teams
are working very, very
closely to make sure
that these all work by the
time we go to public beta.
As of the alpha state,
it's still in progress.
All right.
So let's look at this in action.
So basically we
have an application,
and that application, we're
going to do things to it.
And the demos will show
how the monitoring features
come into play.
But Steren wrote
this, so let's let
him describe the
architecture to us.
STEREN GIANNINI: Let's
see what the app does,
and then I will explain
you how it's done.
So simply this is a website.
The title is Web Page Watcher.
So what this website
does is that you
submit it a URL of a web page,
and then it will watch it
for changes, visual changes.
So for example, on
this test example app,
I wrote a static web
page that from when
the button changed color.
And as you see, my web
page watcher website
captured those two
what we call keyframes.
So there was a change, they
were captured visually.
So let's switch
back to the slides
to see how we built that
using serverless products.
So the first thing to know is
that every five minutes, there
is Cloud Scheduler,
which is going
to trigger another service.
And the service is what we
call All Task Scheduler.
So the Task Scheduler will
query the database for web pages
to watch.
So the database will return OK,
I have this set of web pages.
Go watch them.
The scheduler for each
of those web pages
will create an event
in Cloud PubSub,
and this event will be take
a screenshot of that page.
So one event per
screenshot to take.
This is the only
job of that service.
The second service has only
one job, taking screenshots
of the web page it gets.
So this other service is
written in App Engine.
We could have written a
Cloud function for that
because both App
Engine and Cloud
Functions support
all of the libraries
that you need to
run Headless Chrome.
So the screenshot
service is running Chrome
without a visual interface.
But it's rendering a web
page, taking a screenshot,
and that's it.
That's the only job
of that service.
It's super simple.
Literally hundreds line of code.
I'm not going to show them,
but very simple to write.
Once it took a screenshot, it
will store it in Cloud Storage.
Simple.
And anytime something is added
to that Cloud Storage bucket,
an event is triggered,
and this event
will trigger a Cloud Function.
This Cloud function
also has only one job.
It's comparing the new
file with a reference file.
And if there is a difference, it
will store this new screenshot
as the new reference, and it
will capture it as a keyframe.
So here, if there
is a difference,
it will keep the new image
that it just received.
That's basically what's
happening every five minutes.
This is configured
with Cloud Scheduler.
And then when I open my
Web Page Watcher website
as a user, what I'm doing
is I'm hitting a front end
service that is regular
website service that queries,
of course, the database
to look for the web pages
that we are tracking.
And also, when I look at the
details of one of those web
pages, it will query the
Cloud storage to return
the keyframes of that web page.
So you see four services, four
miscroservices, each of them
super, super simple.
But brought together, they are
doing something very complex
in a very reliable way.
And so this is all demo app.
And now Jay is going to go
over some different scenario
for monitoring and
troubleshooting this app.
So what you should
know is that I
did a release of that
application 30 minutes ago.
So let's see if this
release is healthy
JAY JUDKOWITZ: I'm sure
it's going to be great.
So we're going to talk
about two features that
are going to come into
play in the first demo.
The first feature
is a SLO feature.
So like I said, I deferred
earlier that we're
going to dive into this.
SREs, like I said,
they don't chase around
problems playing whack-a-mole
with pager all day
because, again, the
toil would be too high
and the scale wouldn't be there.
What they really
worry about is what
affects the customer directly.
So let's look at a
very trivial example.
What if the CPU runs hot?
Well, that could
affect the customer.
But we've done the
obvious automation there.
We've implemented auto scaling.
It scales out.
The CPU drops, and if there was
any degradation of performance,
it goes away.
There's no point
in paging somebody.
It works, right?
But no matter how much
automation you do,
no matter how much thought
you put into the system,
you always make it
better and better
but you never get rid
of every last problem.
And so at some point,
there's something
you didn't automate away
and it affects the user.
And that's what
the SLIs are about
is quantifying the
effect to the user.
So what does the
user care about?
Do they care about your CPU?
No, not at all.
What do they care about?
They care about two
obvious examples.
Availability.
What percentage of my calls
come back with a 200 response?
They care about latency.
Let's say a particular
service works well up
to 300 milliseconds
response time.
So I care what
percentage of my requests
come back in 300
milliseconds or less.
So those are indicators.
Those percentages are the
service level indicators.
Once you know what
it is you're watching
and what it is your
users care about,
you put an objective on that.
And that objective is
sort of the promise you're
making to yourself, whether you
externalize the promise or not,
saying, this is how I
know my thing is working.
For example, I might
want 99.9% 200 responses.
Or I might want 99% of
my calls to come back
in under 300 milliseconds.
Now you notice in those
examples I threw out there,
I didn't use the number 100.
And there are a couple
of good reasons for that.
One is if you needed 100%,
you'd have zero flexibility
to do anything.
And any change anywhere
that broke anything
would break your promise.
So 100 doesn't often make sense.
But second, people are
pretty good at writing
apps that are resilient.
You get a 500?
Retry, it'll probably work.
Web services, like if
you go to a web page
and 99 out of 100 times
it loads satisfactorily,
and the last time it
doesn't load satisfactorily,
you'll be OK.
So having a non-100% SLO is
a really, really important
concept.
Now when you subtract
the objective
from 100, what you're left
with is the error budget.
That is, how many calls
you're allowed to have that,
in an availability
case, that aren't 200,
or in the latency case, that
are slower than you'd like.
And by the way, there's other
SLOs and SLIs out there.
I'm just going over
the most common ones.
And the error budget
is critical thing.
SREs really, really,
really focus on this
because if your error budget
is low, or below zero,
you should stop adding features.
You should start
fixing technical debt.
You should hold off release.
You should fix the system
and make it more reliable.
What if the error
budget is super high?
Well, you know
crank up the dial.
Say, hey, we're not
experimenting enough.
We're giving users more
reliability than they need.
And that seems like it
would be a good thing
except for two problems.
One, they could
start relying on that
and you may not be
able to maintain that.
Or two, you may
not be giving them
the features they want because
your customers want reliability
and they want features.
So make it as
reliable as they need,
and then get as many
features in as can.
Spend your budget,
your money budget.
And then what if your SLO is
OK, you haven't broken it,
but it's dropping precipitously?
Well, that's when
you page somebody.
If you have a precipitous
drop in error budget
in an SLO for an indicator that
a customer really cares about,
that's when the SRE gets woken
up at 2:00 in the morning.
Now I've grayed out
this third concept, SLA,
because it's not
really an SRE concept,
but it's a business concept,
and people asked about it
in this context.
SLAs are when you give some kind
of guarantee to your customers,
maybe like I'll
give you a refund
if I don't meet this SLO.
By and large,
again, like I said,
not necessarily an SRE concept.
Obviously the advice here is if
you have an SLO tied to an SLA,
you should probably have a
much stricter SLO internally
that you're not publishing
because you certainly
don't want your finance
and legal to be the ones
notified the first time
something goes wrong.
You want to work
really, really hard
to keep customer
happiness high, and then
have your money back
guarantee at a higher
level of dysfunction.
So feature number one is
going to be that SLO feature.
Feature number two is an
integrated service dashboard.
So Stackdriver has
a lot of pieces,
and I kind of rattled
them off before.
And they're all really
awesome, and independently
they all add a lot of value.
But they're all in different
pages, different domains.
I have a dashboard page.
I have an incident page.
I have a log page.
I have an error report
page, a trace page.
But if I'm monitoring a
particular service, what
I really want to know is,
what are all of the signals
that I have for
that one service,
and put those all
in one place, and be
able to have an integrated
troubleshooting experience that
goes from I have an SLO
problem to here are my metrics,
to here are my logs, and
go deeper and deeper.
And so that's what
we've put together.
So let's do Demo One.
Let's have a bird's eye
view of microservice
and see what's going on here.
So what we're looking at
is the screenshot service.
You can see the name here.
Here you can see the timeline.
I can zoom in to
a particular time.
We'll show that
later in the demo.
We have an incident
history, event history.
And like I said, we're
going to start with the SLOs
because the SLOs are
what we're managing to.
We're not managing
CPU or memory.
We're managing to the SLO.
And we have an SLO that says
we want 90% availability
in the last seven rolling days.
And as you can see,
we're doing pretty well.
We had a big hiccup yesterday.
I guess Steren and I
were practicing the demo.
And we were doing really well
and there was this little blip.
I'm not sure what that
was, but blips happen.
It's a small one
and we survived it.
But something bad is
happening right now.
We're definitely
not getting 90%.
We're something like 60%
of successful responses.
And the error budget,
accordingly, is low.
So we've been playing with
this over the last week
and we're under zero.
If it really looked
like this in real life,
everybody would be all hands
on deck for reliability surge.
But right now you can
see the error budget,
even though it was below zero,
it's dropping even further.
And then we can look at
the metrics for the service
and say what's going on here?
So this is a lot of
information here.
But what's cool is we have
this group buy and filter
functionality.
So for example, Steren
mentioned he did an upgrade.
So let's group by version ID.
And so now you could see we
have all these different--
we have the new and the old.
But there's still a
lot of lines there.
I just want to know about
the 500 response codes.
So I can filter to that.
Response code 500.
And here we go.
So this is the new one
and this is the old one.
So like I said, the old one
had that one little blip.
But that's not bad.
That went away.
The new one is giving us
errors, and more and more errors
all the time.
And this is not good.
It's burning through
error budget.
So I could worry about
debugging the code or whatnot,
but right now I just
want to roll back.
So I go over to App Engine, and
I can go to the old version,
and I can migrate
all the traffic.
And if we come back here, what
we'll find in a minute or two
is that we'll see
the errors go down,
and we'll come back
to the SLO page,
and we'll see the SLIs going up.
But for the sake of--
we can come back
to that at the end.
You can see already
the SLIs starting
to flatten out pretty quickly.
So that is the first demo.
And let's see what
we're going to do next.
So features that are going
to show up in the next demo
include distributed tracing.
So just by show of
hands, who here has
used distributed tracing before?
No?
OK.
One person.
Awesome.
OK, so we're going to display
it for everybody else.
Like Steren said, if I
have microservice-based
application-- he showed
one with, I don't know,
five microservices.
But what if you have
tens, or some people
have even hundreds
of microservices.
If something is
slow, why is it slow?
Do you just start
at the front end
and try to figure
out all the way back
where the slowness
is coming from?
That'll take you all day.
What distributed traces
do is they sample the code
and they basically say,
OK, for this transaction,
I'm going to trace this one.
I'm going to find
out how much latency
came from this
microservice, how much came
from this microservice, how much
came from this microservice.
And it draws a picture.
It ties it together
into a waterfall.
And then you're able to
see, just at a glance,
where's the slow span?
And when you figure out
which span is the slow one,
you can then go into other
tools like we'll talk about next
to figure out why.
So distributed
tracing is a really,
really, really powerful
tool for figuring out
what's wrong with
your microservices.
The instrumentation for
that is open census.
And that is a vendor
agnostic instrumentation.
And we're working with a lot
of our partners and competitors
on this to make sure that
when you can get tracing,
it's not just tracing
for Stackdriver,
but it's tracing for whoever.
So if you switch tools,
maybe as an ops person,
you're switching tools
and that's a bummer.
But for your developers,
they don't care.
They still have census.
Now like I said, what
about why is it slow?
So once you figure out
which span is slow,
you can go to the profiler.
And the profiler tells
you continuously,
also through sampling,
which functions in your code
are taking up CPU, which
ones are taking up time.
You could figure
out who your problem
child is down to the function
level within the microservice.
And so that's a
really powerful tool
that we've released recently.
So let's look into
a performance issue.
So again-- sorry, just
on the last demo--
we'll come back at the end.
I just want to make
sure for time that we--
so we're at different
service now.
We're at default service.
So on the default
service, you can
see again we wanted
less than half
a second on 95% of the calls.
We were doing good except
for our big test there.
And again, the rollout has
caused us a problem here.
So we can go into the metrics
and see what's going on.
And this heat map
here is showing us
that this is where the
latency generally was hottest,
but now it's up here.
And if we want to go even
deeper into more proof,
again, we can group
by version ID.
And if I look at the old one,
that's the latency I want.
And if I look at the
new one, yeah, that's
the latency I didn't want.
So pretty stark, pretty
manufactured demo,
but you get an idea
of how the tools work
and how they show
you this stuff.
So now again, I can go
and fix the problem.
So I can go to the old and
migrate the traffic back.
And like I said, that'll take
effect in a couple of minutes.
We'll be able to come back
at the end of the demo
and show you the updated graphs.
But I don't want to roll back.
I want to know what
the heck happened here.
So let's go to the
Diagnostics tab.
And in the Diagnostics
tab we have traces.
And so this is a 3,400
millisecond trace.
That's like seven times what
I set the SLI objective to.
And the problem could
have been anywhere.
It could have been
in Steren's code
or it could have been in
something he was calling.
And if you look,
here's Steren's code,
and here is all the
things he called.
Well, Data Store is
behaving really nice.
This Fetch Results function is
behaving really, really nice.
This is not behaving so nice.
So this is where we're going
to focus and figure out.
So let me call Steren
back up, and can you
tell us what happened there?
STEREN GIANNINI: I'll
try to diagnose that.
I think it's probably
not network related.
Otherwise we would
see this pattern
on that trace waterfall.
So I think this is
more code related.
Let's dive into Profiler
and try to understand
where that time goes.
So I'm opening Stackdriver
Profiler right here.
To get it, I open it
from the Cloud console.
So this is Stackdriver Profiler
that you recently released.
What you're looking at
here is the Heap profile
for my application.
And usually when I
look at such graphs,
very rich graphs, but the
patterns I'm looking at
are very long spans that
are at the very bottom
because that means that one
thing is taking a lot of time.
So here I don't see that.
But you know, I'm looking
at Heap profile right here.
Let's go to wall clock time.
This would be CPU.
And let's filter
out what we call
the program frames,
which are basically
when my program is idle.
So this I want to filter
out because it's probably
when no requests come in.
And right here you
see there is something
that looks suspicious here.
There is this very long
span, and the function
is named Heath Prime.
Did I just release two
productions, something
that computes prime numbers?
Sorry.
I was testing things
and I'm sorry.
Just double check.
So I'm going to compare
the old version.
Yeah, this one looks like
a normal profile waterfall,
so this is no long span.
And if I go to the
new version, then yes,
if we look at on
the right, we can
see the same kind of CPU usage.
But the majority of
all time is spent
computing these prime numbers.
So I'm sorry about that.
I think it's good
you rolled it back,
and I will remove
that from the code.
So this is sort of a
profiler continuously
profiling my app really without
me having to do anything.
So let's switch back.
So how I fix that, I
would open my editor
and simply fix the code itself.
Now going back to the
last demo, the tools
we will use in that demo are
on Stackdriver Error Reporting.
So Stackdriver Error
Reporting is automatically
monitoring your logs for
some application errors.
So for example, when there is a
crash, most of the time in your
logs you will see a stack
trace, an exception.
And so Stackdriver,
in real time,
is looking at all of your
logs looking for crashes.
When it finds a crash,
it will capture it.
And when it finds the
same kind of crash,
it will group them
together so that
what you will focus on when you
open Error Reporting are groups
of errors, not single
entries, but really they
are grouped
meaningfully together.
So it's all real time.
And the way to get it
is simply via logging.
So that means that on all
of our serverless products,
because you get
logging out of the box,
you get also error
reporting out of the box.
And the second tool I
will use in that last demo
is Stackdriver Debugger.
So Stackdriver Debugger
is an amazing technology.
I told you before I'm not
able to SSH in my VMs.
But that doesn't mean I
cannot inspect the state
of my instances.
And basically what
Debugger allows you to do
is to inspect the state
of a running application
without slowing it down.
So it's not like a breakpoint.
It doesn't stop the execution.
No, no, no.
It's when you put a
snapshot, as we call them,
it will snapshot the
entire state of the app
and then continue the execution.
But you will have
visibility into the state
of your application.
So we have snapshots.
And we have one of my favorite
feature, which is logpoints.
So how many times did you just
redeploy a new version just
by adding some log statements
because you couldn't figure out
what was wrong on production?
And what Debugger
Logpoints allow you to do
are simply to add log statements
dynamically in your code
without having to redeploy
because under the hood,
we are using the exact same
technology as for snapshots,
which are that
every time the code
will execute at that point,
we will snapshot the state,
and we will print a log
entry into your logs.
So you can dynamically add
a log statement to your code
without redeploying.
To setup Stackdriver Debugger
you have to import a library.
This library, when you
are not using Debugger,
has no impact on your app,
and when you're using it,
has very, very low impact.
So I recommend to
import it in case,
for the future, something needs
to be diagnosed in production.
So my last demo will be using
Error Reporting and Debugger
to understand an application
error based on an availability
alert.
So let's switch to the demo.
I received this email
from Stackdriver
telling me that
there's a new error
in my microservice screenshot.
I could also have received
a push notification
if I was on my smartphone.
We have the Google
Cloud Mobile app,
and you receive the same kind
of notification on your mobile.
So OK.
Let's click that call to
action, View Error Details,
let me understand
what's going wrong here.
Let me zoom in a little bit
to one hour to see better.
So theree is a new rror.
You see it happened 37
times in that timeframe.
Well, obviously it's
not the first time
we see it because we rehearsed.
But last seen it
was 10 minutes ago.
I think it was last seen
when Jay rolled back
to the previous version.
So it seemed that the
error is under control.
But still, I would
like to diagnose it.
Well, actually, you know what?
Let me roll back to
the broken version.
Otherwise the rest of
the demo will not work.
This was this one.
Sorry.
OK.
So what you see here are the
details of a given error group.
So at the bottom you have
many samples of that error.
I can expand, I can
see the stack trace.
And at the top, you
have a sample stack
trace for that error group.
And you see we
clean it up for you,
so we remove the frames
that are the no JS frames,
or in that case,
it's express JS.
So this is framework code.
You as a developer don't
want to worry about that.
What you want to
worry is your code.
And this code is in
server.js is my code.
All right.
So something's wrong.
Let's hit Auto
Reload to make sure.
Yeah, you see it start to happen
again when I rolled forward
to that new version.
So let's dive into the code.
So I'm just clicking
that file, server.js,
and it opens
Stackdriver Debug View.
What Debug does, it will
automatically set a snapshot
at this point of the code.
So you see I did not have to
provide my code because when
I deploy to App Engine, I
already push my source code.
So Debugger can easily
fetch that same source code
and allow you to set
snapshots on that source code.
So let's wait for
the error to trigger,
or we can trigger it directly by
hitting the screenshot service.
As you see, it produces
internal server error.
And when I do that, OK,
the snapshot just hit.
And so it's zoom a little bit.
What you see, so the snapshot
was put here at this line.
And here I can
inspect the variables.
So I see that URL is
actually undefined.
Well, OK, so now I understand
better the URL that starts
with, that obviously cannot
be called because the variable
doesn't exist, is undefined.
So that will crash
my application.
So if I want to double check,
I can add more snapshots.
But at this point, I'm
pretty sure about what's
going wrong here.
So my action immediately,
I will roll back
to the previous version.
And I will fix my code
simply by opening my editor.
So you see, this was
live production code
that we inspected and we got
the values of the variables
thanks to Stackdriver Debugger.
That's the end of our demos.
Let's switch back to
the slides for a recap.
So the first thing is that
we've shown you a little bit
about the Stackdriver Suite.
There are many other things
we haven't shown, like alerts.
But for you to know,
Stackdriver has many tools.
We introduced today the
Stackdriver service dashboard,
SLO monitoring
that are new today,
and Profiler was
released very recently.
Then the other take
away that we want
you to remember is that
Stackdriver and serverless
on GCP, this is a checkmark.
Stackdriver has all you need
to monitor and troubleshoot
your serverless
applications and functions.
And for a lot of it,
it's out of the box.
And lastly, we encourage
you to try it out.
So on the serverless
side, we announce
in alpha the serverless
add-on for GKE.
You can request access.
I think, Jay, you want to talk a
bit more about the early access
program of service monitoring?
JAY JUDKOWITZ: The service
monitoring, including the SLOs,
is in early access.
There's a Google
form to fill out.
If you reach out to
reps or to Steren or I,
we can get you access to that.
All right.
So contact, it's jjudkowitz.
It's my last name at Google.com.
And you can reach out and I can
get you access to the survey
so you can sign up for the
EAP for service monitoring.
Same for me.
If you're interested in
the serverless add-on
or try it out on newly released
runtimes for serverless,
it's steren@google.com, my
first name at Google.com.
Feel free to reach out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]